[Musique]
stéphanie grammond alex tanguay luc
ferrandez bonsoir bonsoir visite éclair
de monsieur trudeau
qui est allé rencontrer le président
zielinski jo faire entendre et monsieur
trudeau et le président et linky sur le
rôle du canada pour vient tout de suite
des canadiens vont toujours être
solidaire de l'ukraine pas seulement
parce qu on est ami avec l'ukraine et
bien seront l'est mais aussi parce que
les préceptes qu'on est en train de
défendre que les ukrainiens sont en
train de défendre avec leur vie contre
l'invasion illégale de la lumière
poutine sont des principes qui nous
gardent tous en sécurité à travers le
monde et qui doivent être défendus à
chaque étape
tous nous
justifions litres cette vertu d'un
mandat des nations
unies sans compter que
sur ce sujet ce blu et je mange du
talion leur esprit un premier ministre
formé chez le leader canada non mon jeu
de paume orthez
le canada est un leader dit le président
de l'éduquer et il est le deuxième après
les états unis difficile d'en demander
plus ça
c'est vraiment une déclaration que
quatre qui a dû faire plaisir à la vice
première ministre alec j'ai commencé
avec vous et au premier ministre hugo
louis et en même temps ça permette de
décocher une petite flèche aux européens
parce que le numéro un une deux en
termes de dons sont des pays qui sont
même pas en europe alors alors que les
frontières de l'europe sont menacés par
la russie donc ça permet
d'envoyer une petite la colère de la
tête à la france à l'allemagne et à
d'autres pays en même temps mais oui si
c'est d'abord une visite qui je pense
est important
l'assemblée les symboles en diplomatie
sont très importants deuxième pays du g7
en tant que dirigeant se déplacer après
boris johnson la grande bretagne on est
un allié très très près de l'ukraine on
l'est depuis longtemps promis pays en
1991 à reconnaître l'indépendance de
l'ukraine on est avec lui on a formé les
soldats ukrainien au sein de l'otan donc
on en joue un rôle important puis je
pense que céline skihorizon quasi au
pourrait peut-être vouloir en faire plus
mais on ne peut pas on n'est pas un pays
qu une grande armée qui a énormément de
stocks en réserve comme les états unis
qui peuvent se permettre de faire
énormément dont on est probablement la
limite de ce qu'on peut faire mais
l'appui diplomatique que justin trudeau
est allé apporter je pense que sa seule
issue craignez vous le prendre
certainement oui parce que l'udc et
stéphanie temps on dit oui ça nous était
clair c'est quand même une visite c'est
de se rendre sur place a quand même du
poids en tout cas au niveau symbolique
c'est un poids énorme le
oui tout à fait et en plus il faut dire
que c'est pas juste le fait de s'y
rendre c'est aussi le fait que le canada
peut jouer un rôle d'influencé auprès
des des pays qui sont contre l'ukraine
et pour la russie parce que quand on
regarde vous médias on a l'impression
que le monde entier et pour l'ukraine
non l'inde la chine et surtout le brésil
je veux dire surtout le brésil je
m'explique pourquoi continue d'appuyer
la russie et le président lula à celui
qui va devenir le président voulait
certainement rapidement au brésil a
déclaré zidane qui est au moins aussi
coupables que poutine dans les morts
qu'il ya en ce moment en ukraine par sa
volonté belliciste de faire la guerre et
donc la trudeau a peu joué un rôle il
peut agir sur un partenaire delà de
l'amérique du sud et tenté de jouer de
son influence alors cette visite là ça
démontre l'engagement mais il pourrait y
avoir des suites stéphanie vous êtes
d'accord que deux sur l'importance de la
visite
je pense que oui
déjà le canada ne fait beaucoup avec le
trio de ministres la madame jolie madame
un an et évidemment la vice première
ministre et christopher nolan qui
déracine ukrainienne donc on sait qu'ils
ont elles se sont beaucoup d'émules
depuis le début de la guerre mais je
pense que c'était important que justin
trudeau se présente il y ait en vain une
valeur de symbole le fait d'être à kiev
qui est une ville l'a évidemment on
aurait pu penser
lors de des premiers des premières genre
à l'invasion que la russie ferait qu'une
bouchée du pays et puis finalement on se
rend compte que deux mois plus tard
c'est pour le coc et si une premier
ministre du canada pour se rendre
d'abord en sécurité c'est que
manifestement et ça tient bon et ça
c'est un symbole important envoyé de
dhiba on ouvre l'ambassade on considère
que c'est que c'est possible de faire
tant mieux et puis oui le canada est
quand même c'est une fleur que le
monsieur zelensky nuit en voit en lui
disant voilà vous êtes vous êtes parmi
les premiers en haut de la liste de pays
qu'on veut remercier mais c'est bien
pour monsieur trudeau qui est super fois
se faire reprocher de ne pas en faire
assez
mais à la hauteur de nos moyens je pense
quand même qu'on a on a contribué en
imposant des sanctions en étant à
l'avant garde de ce côté là alors on
voit on a hissé le drapeau devant
l'immeuble de l'ambassade canadienne à
kiev donc on a rouvert
l'ambassade pour des pour le pour la
diplomatie et non pas pour les affaires
consulaires à l'oeil mais on se dit que
ça viendra
c'est peut-être la seule petite tache
dans ce dossier là du côté du canada
sait qu'on a encore eu beaucoup de
difficultés avec les services
consulaires pour les réfugiés surtout au
tout début comme on avait eu en
afghanistan au système immunitaire c'est
à l'immigration qui est devenu frais
dysfonctionnelle lorsqu'une crise éclate
quelque part et on se demande un peu le
canada c'est quoi sa politique
officielle lorsqu'il ya une gestion de
crise parce que dès que ça brasse un peu
on fait notre ambassade qui on s'en va
tous les pays ne font pas cela la france
la grande bretagne n'ont jamais fermé
leur ambassade à kiev vont continuer à
offrir des ressortissants évidemment de
leur pays mais aussi aux réfugiés
potentiels une aide consulaire en
afghanistan et britanniques sont restés
très très longtemps le plus longtemps
possible les hourras c'est aussi des
procès ou sinon on quitte avant même
qu'il se passe quelque chose les
ukrainiennes 18 nous ont aidés en
afghanistan les ukrainiens ou sont aidés
là-bas bon parce qu'on avait quitté moi
et c'est peut-être que la prochaine
étape c'est leur médecin en place le
sait quoi les critères qui guident au
ministère à faire et un peu plus
longtemps pour donner un coup de main
c'est quand même cela principales
responsabilités avant de parler de
diplomatie c'est d'aider le monde sur
place c'est peut-être là où on a encore
pas mal de ficelles à attacher mais pour
le reste la visite a plutôt bien et
voilà plq on a vu le tableau
des départs annoncés en a onze en aura
sûrement d'autres les voici des vieux
routier des piliers dans certains cas du
parti qui était arrivé soit sous
monsieur charest
ou ensuite bon bref je veux entendre
monsieur arcand madame anglade et la
candidate dans ville mont royal
outremont madame c'est la course on
écoute je confirme le fait que je ne
vais pas solliciter un nouveau mandat
dans la circonscription de mont royal
outremont aux élections du mois
d'octobre prochain après plus d'une
quinzaine d'années en politique le temps
est venu de laisser ma place à une
nouvelle génération qui va apporter des
nouvelles idées également pour le québec
c'est clair que pour le parti libéral du
québec il ya une période de renouveau
parce qu'il ya des gens qui ont
contribué à la vie politique de manière
très très forte et je pense que pierre
en est un bon exemple une énorme
contribution et je pense qu'à presque
pas de poste que pierre arcand n'a pas
occupé au sein de notre formation
l'information politique mais encore une
fois je pense que comme comme formations
les plus riches de toute cette
expérience là on est capable de pouvoir
compter sur les conseils l'expérience
les idées qu'ils amènent en même temps
c'est ça va ça attire des personnes qui
ont envie de faire de la politique
pendant les dix les 15 prochaines années
avec nous
la pandémie nous amener à réfléchir et à
identifier ce qui compte le plus dans
nos vies nous devons urgemment poser les
gestes qui s'imposent pour créer de la
richesse partout au québec tout en
protégeant l'environnement à mon sens
les sujets à saveur nationaliste
identitaire qui nous divisent ne devrait
pas occuper autant de place dans le
débat public
madame 7 la queer as en tête la loi 21
le projet de loi pour modifier la loi
101 également monsieur legault
d'ailleurs étonnamment sur son twitter
qui sait des choses mais elle est de la
partie en dix ans le plq présent une
candidate anti nationaliste avec mont
royal ça c'était alex assez étonnant se
jouera à peine le jour n'est pas
terminée et il inesis mêle de ça en date
bon qu'est ce que ça nous dit monte puis
l'autre question je vous pose et je
voulais posera fait tout de suite c'est
quand même là on veut bien qu'il ya un
roulement de génération que c'est très
bien mais ça commence à faire beaucoup
de départs mais d'abord sur l'arrivée de
madame c est la plus à l'est que tour de
temps bon d'abord françois legault pour
beaucoup d'ambition d'un mont royal
outremont c'était clairement un message
était destiné au reste du québec pour
l'ensemble la campagne électorale veut
se présenter comme le champion du québec
le champion national istres permettait
pour lui de répéter que à ses yeux les
libéraux ne sont pas nationaliste excès
de candidature le prouve mais ça rien à
voir avec la lutte locale on s'entend
que c'est un message qui vise l ensemble
de la population de la campagne
électorale selon lui sur les départs des
libéraux c'est un mélange c'est vrai que
certains libéraux qui ont donné beaucoup
à la politique sont là depuis longtemps
qui veulent passer à autre chose pierre
arcand en fait certainement partie les
trios ou s'ils en sont là depuis
longtemps droit d'avoir une vision de la
politique il y en a d'autres pour qui
probablement que les sondages
défavorables il dit passé quatre années
possiblement dans la pollution ne leur
sourit pas beaucoup et qui le précipite
peut-être un peu leur décision est
probablement un mélange des deux le
résultat est quand même que 40% du
caucus jusqu'à présent annoncé son
départ on va probablement ce qu'ont à
50% c'est quand même beaucoup et
beaucoup si on fait l'analogie du hockey
reconstruire une équipe c'est important
mais ça prend quelques vétérans
d'expérience vous encadrer les jeunes si
on veut pas une série de défaites alors
peut-être que là il faudra trouver un
mélange au parti libéral quand il sait
bien faire mais on n'est pas fan un peu
d'expérience aussi à l'assemblée
nationale stéphanie
oui effectivement c'est cdu/csu
roulement de personnel
si on est à l'entreprise on pourrait
s'élever mais puisse décider des gros
canons qui est des grandes pointures qui
s'en vont monsieur arcand madame
thériault c'est des gens qui ont fait
beaucoup madame thériault quand elle
était aux côtés du ministère la
consommation que changer beaucoup de
choses il y en a d'autres qui ont pas
annoncé encore mais on est dans
l'incertitude monsieur météo qui était
ministre des finances puis à qui on doit
le finalement le grand ménage de nos
finances publiques le ministre actuel
est le premier à le reconnaître et j'ai
donc c'est des gens quand même qu'ils
sont d'expérience et
la sicile qui est tous en même temps oui
le renouveau mais bon
c'est sûr que ça va être un défi mais
mais bon on va voir madame c'est cela
qui est intéressant c'est qu'on dirait
que se positionne plus de façons le plus
ferme sur les enjeux justement
nationaliste le parti libéral avait été
abaissé et séduit un peu davantage
l'électorat francophone pour essayer
d'aller chercher des votes à l'extérieur
de l'île mais non c'est que des parties
anglophone qui vont peut-être se former
ou se sont entendus en train de l'être
alors ça ça peut diviser le vois de chez
les libéraux mais le bon la voix elle
qui qui se positionne de façon plus
ferme c'est peut-être un message aussi
qu'elle est ce qu'elle est c'est
d'envoyer de ce côté là très bien lu qu
une des deux questions celle que vous
inspire d'abord est-ce que
monsieur legault qui va faire flèche de
tout bois pour montrer qu'il est le
champion national ici et que toute
critique la loi 21 devient une critique
anti nationaliste
wee cc sont assez le rôle qu'il joue et
puis en même temps pour la loi 85 la
réplique je profite de votre côté pas
juste le pq d'ailleurs québec solidaire
et beaucoup d'autres acteurs en lui
disant vous allez pas assez loin vous
êtes trop
vous prenez trop de précautions vous
êtes trop timide ça ne donnera rien
alors lui de se présenter en disant
voyez vous moi je suis le représentant
du juste milieu mais aussi je défends le
vrai nationalisme québécois par rapport
au parti libéral maintenant sur la
question des la question du départ c'est
une chose est dans l'opposition quand tu
as perdu tu veux tu as perdu par 3 ou 4
pour ça et tu tapes tu as une chance
réelle de gagner après 4 c'en est une
autre d'arriver dans un parti qui aurait
15 % 14 pour cent de la faveur public et
qui a aucune chance peut-être de
d'arriver au pouvoir dans quatre ans et
dont 6 8 ans dans l'opposition nos
positions c'est quelque chose qui use il
faut que tu au courant de tous les
dossiers au fait de tous les dossiers
constamment en mode vigilance en mode
critique c'est loin d'être facile
voilà loin d'être facile de recruter des
gens là où l'étranger loin le cuites à
la déjà dans huit ambre
nous a heureusement des chiffres nous
avait dit qu à moins donnera deux
renversements et rapide
oui oui mais la prochaine wii à moins
d'un renversement rap et de la prochaine
présidentielle mais l'hôte après dans
quatre ans mais là c'est très très
longtemps le parti il faudrait que le
parti libéral réussisse son virage
régional est d'ailleurs pas de chance
pour le parti libéral est au moment où
il annonçait qu'il y allait avoir une
politique des régions de chartes des
régions 1 il mène une gouvernance
régionale guy lafleur mort le même jour
alors pas de chance dans la réinvention
ça s'est passé sous silence on sait pas
où ça va lui adresser à turf et nomen
andré arthur qui a frappé à peu près sur
tout le monde
avec beaucoup de démagogie parfois on va
écouter
me sers tour lui-même quelques réactions
pour vient un tour de table pour la fin
en tant que polémiste j'ai besoin de
dire des choses qui me sont importantes
et j'ai besoin que les gens comprennent
qu'ils sont obligés d'être d'accord avec
moi mais que si je le dis c'est parce
que je le pense
arthur disait je revendique le droit de
m'adresser à mes auditeurs comme je
parle à mes amis alors ça a changé le
ton avec lequel les animateurs
s'adressait au public en nombre je pense
que
jusqu'au milieu des années 80 tout le
monde travailler d'une façon beaucoup
plus coincé en ondes et par la suite ça
comme ouvert la porte à la façon de
s'exprimer des animateurs
je l'écouté je travaillais mieux c'était
jusqu'à pâques et finissons son émission
c'est quelqu'un qui était amoureux mais
baissent on fera parler
il a effectivement donné un ton nouveau
à la radio il a contribué à une
révolution la radio puis ça deviendra
beaucoup plusieurs années plus tard la
radio de québec mais tour de table le
ferrandez on a vu passer depuis hier des
réactions
jusqu'à la toute fin il aurait été
lui-même en tout cas
oui malheureusement
moi je connais évidemment c'est normal
que sa famille il ya une chance aux deux
jeunes êtres nous qui dit à propos de
deal à faire l'important c'est d'être
aimé il semblerait qu'il a été démis par
sa famille et il faut reconnaître le
deuil de sa famille ceci étant dit c'est
un homme que mis son intelligence à son
don le don de la parole dont la
communication au service de la argh au
service de la de du chaos et du et du
rejet d'une partie de notre population
que ce soit les homosexuels les
homosexuels les musulmans les haïtiens à
de nombreuses reprises il à jeter des
anathèmes sur des gens qui étaient dans
la douleur des mois je ne plus prendre
et jour de sa mort mais je suis content
que ce soit enfin silencieux alec
un photoshoot je pense reconnaître
l'excellent communicateur qu'il était je
suis un peu d'accord avec lui sur le
fait que
l'attaqué les plus vulnérables était
imbuvable c'est en effet un personnage
très controversé moi j'ai découvert la
chambre des communes elle est arrivée en
2006 faut pas oublier qu'il a été député
pendant cinq ans député indépendant les
consommateurs il y avait même laissé là
voilier certains moments 2008 parce
qu'il jugeait qu'il était un des leurs
et pourquoi diviser le vote et faire
rentrer le bloc québécois on présentait
pas de conservateurs dans
portneuf-jacques-cartier c'est
finalement la vague auront de 2009 à
2011 les rues raison d'andré ressemer
l'était pas du tout à la chambre des
communes comme il était à la radio moi
je me souviens on s'attendait à ce que
le député andré ac se soient colorés qui
attaque tous azimuts qui soit
extrêmement controversée peau du tour et
parle à peu près pas médiocre de son
travail un cap
il considère qu'on a conduit son autobus
donc de faire l'instrument mais les fois
où il l'était à la chambre des communes
on peut pas dire qu'il était équivalent
à son personnage radiophonique et ça ça
nous aurait étonné à l'époque où je le
couvrais il est temps un député un peu
comme un autre malgré l'évident amant la
réputation qu'il suivait stéphanie mais
on peut pas lui nie qu'il y avait le
sens de la nouvelle parce que lui-même a
fait un gazouillis sur twitter pour le
jour de sa mort pour pour faire pour
tirer sa révérence donc manifestement
ils avaient de scoop mais donc oui c'est
sûr que évidemment est maintenant qu'il
est décidé nos condoléances vont à sa
famille mais d'un autre côté moi je peux
pas m'empêcher de penser que son
héritage en termes journalistiques qui
aura été plutôt du côté de bons
souvenirs de tous ces progrès de tous
ses procès en diffamation de tout ce
qu'il a pu dire l'auberge de diviser la
société et
sexuelle les contes noirs contre les
mines les musulmans tout c est quand
même assez malheureux merci beaucoup à
vous trois c'est tout le temps qu on a
bonne soirée au revoir merci
merci merci pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit